hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal
wann ich kann es selbst kaum fassen wie
schnell ich wieder mit meinem tagebuch
zurück bin ja danke danke danke schön
danke dass dem ich euch das letzte mal
mit seinem krassen cliffhanger
zurückgelassen habe dachte ich dass ich
die nächste folge ein bisschen früher
machen und deshalb geht es auch gleich
weiter wo ist dieser thema ich habe
keine ahnung was passiert ich bin selber
so gespannt 66 seit 2005 hallo ich habe
einen so süßen jungen kennengelernt er
heißt im im chat aber snoop doggy dogg
wachstumsschub doggy dogg gemerkt ich
hatte damals schon den besten geschmack
ist das betrügen wenn ich ihn so toll
finde auf jeden fall habe ich seine
nummer und er will dass ich den in den
ferien mit nach holland kommen
natürlich geht das nicht gut vielleicht
habe ich bald seine adresse und kann ihn
was schreiben um ein ganz genau wegen
solchen typen hat man früher mal den
kindern gesagt dass sie sich nicht mit
leuten aus dem internet treffen soll
irgend so ein team möchte dass ich mit
ihm nach holland fahren wie altmeister
13 ich habe jetzt wirklich angst weiter
zu lesen ich kann mich einfach nicht
erinnern dass ich mich mit ihm getroffen
habe aber man verdrängt ja manchmal
schlechte erinnerungen also
vielleicht erlebe ich gleich ein trauma
dieser bleibt dabei die klicks sind mein
ist es echt kein thema worüber man sich
lustig machen sollte wirklich siebter
sechs 2005 natalie hätte es nichts
passiert nur dass ich erfahren habe dass
luke doggy dogg typ der rechte im bild
ist aber der ist auch ganz altmodisch
kannte war der profi wer da rein machen
ich habe erfahren dass der rechte typ
ist aber der dass auch ganzen ich bin
manchmal in marvin und manchmal nicht
ist voll komisch andré ist glaube ich
wieder in sophie die kassen auch passen
auch gerade wie gut zusammen
die passen auch irgendwie gut zu sammeln
ich glaub ich war auch mal in wien jetzt
in andré ach so in andre war sie auch
schon mal also ich ja bei andré ist doch
nicht im sophie angriffs laptop ist voll
cool
wir schreiben morgen den deutschtest
voll dumm ich weiß nicht in wenig bis
man an sie will mir nicht sagen in wen
er ist aber er könnte mir mehr vertrauen
als marvin ich bin nicht mit ihm
zusammen
wir sind nicht mehr mit marvin zusammen
und ich hab nicht mal was über die
trennung geschrieben vanessa kommen wenn
ich damals gewusst hätte dass ich jetzt
heute von dem publikum vor lese ich
hätte natürlich viel mehr details
reingepackt okay ich konnte es damals
nicht ahnen dass das tausende von
menschen hören werden was die 13 jährige
vanessa hier rein schreibt zehnter
sechster 2005 hey hier geht es voll
scheiße es liegt auch an marvel warum
muss er auch so blöd sein an regelt
jetzt doch nicht zu sophies geburtstag
ist irgendwie blöd an chris und ich sind
wieder an dem laptop gegangen
wow john cena ist jetzt bei raw das ist
so bei vanessa 14 06 2010 hallo hallo
marvin ist so unfair wenn ich mit ihnen
zusammen bin dann zieht er sich komisch
an aber wenn ich dann so cool und süß
habe ich da gerade wirklich gesagt das
machen sich coole anzieht wenn wir nicht
zusammen sind wenn ich irgendwann mal
eine zeitmaschine finde werde ich zu
dieser zeit zurück fahren und mir eine
richtige stelle verpassen so eine
richtige ohrfeige die du noch drei
kilometer weiter hört in der klasse 6
werde ich französisch machen mit marvin
[Musik]
ich habe wirklich nicht gemerkt was ich
da geschrieben habe dass er das will und
so viel macht es dann auch keine reine
vanessa fünfzehnter sechs seit 2005 ein
irgendwie bin ich in marvin verknallt
das machen wir hier gerade wirklich oder
ihr schaut mir dabei zu wie ich euch
geschichten von der 13-jährigen erzählen
nichts anderes zu sagen hat außer dass
sie in waren ist oder gerade nicht ja du
bist irgendwie in baden verknallt ist
aber mit ihm schluss gemacht und ich bin
eifersüchtig wenn ein mädchen mit ihm
redet schnell jacobi er ist so nett zu
mir
und er ist schon seit einem jahr in mich
verknallt das ist auch okay fast ein
jahr ist so toll und wenn ferien sind
frage ich ihn den alle guten dinge sind
drei ja den ferien frage ich mich ob er
mit mir zusammen sein möchte
denn alle guten dinge sind drei mal
werde ich marvin in den ferien fragen ob
er mit mir zusammen sein möchte
wir wissen es nicht wir werden das das
nächste mal herausfinden bei 337
wie lange sind max und schon zusammen
und ich
frodo und ich sind jetzt drei jahre
zusammen 3 und ein bisschen wow das ist
ja immer so darüber nachdenke nun ein
scheiße